When we analyze the
problem about putting
two blocks along a
frictionless surface
and pushing one and asking,
what is the maximum force such
that block 2 does not slip?
We have three different systems.
And now I want to
focus a little bit
on what would happen if we
just naively chose our systems
as both blocks together.
So let's try to look
at the types of issues
that come up when we do that.
So once again, let's
draw free body diagrams.
Now, we begin.
We're pushing block
1 with a force.
Gravitation is the sum
of these two forces,
because our system here
is block 1 and block 2.
What about normal forces?
Well, the ground is
acting on block 1.
And now, here's the
significant thing.
What about all of those
forces between blocks 1 and 2?
Well, the forces between blocks
1 and 2 are internal forces.
And we saw that they were
friction forces, f12 and f21.
This was the friction force
between the two blocks,
on block 2 due to 1 and the
friction force on block 1
due to 2.
There were normal forces
between these two blocks,
but these are interaction pairs.
And the sum of them are 0.
And so we see that all internal
forces form Newton's third law
interaction pairs and the
vector sum of them are 0.
And that's why I don't
need those internal forces
on my free body diagram.
If I were to draw them, I
would have different arrows.
For instance, I would
have that arrow f21
and I would have the arrow f12.
And you can see that
the sum of those cancel.
I would have the arrow n21 and
I would have the arrow n12.
Arrows in opposite directions.
The interaction pairs
sum to 0, because they
are internal forces.
And again, this enables
us now to just draw
f equals m1 plus m2 times the
acceleration of the system.
And so we have our i hat
and our j hat directions.
Let's pick i hat and j hat.
And now, we didn't include
the kinetic friction force
of the ground in that system.
So let's make sure
that that's there.
And what we have is
f minus f kinetic
equals m1 plus m2 times a.
And in the vertical
direction, we
have n ground 1 minus
m1 plus m2 g equals 0.
That gave us our
same result before.
Notice that f equals
fk plus m1 plus m2 g.
We know this is mu km1 plus
m2 g plus m1 plus m2 g a.
So we have the
acceleration of the system
depends on the force, mu k
m1 plus m2g divided by m1 m2.
But notice because
our static friction
is an internal force
in this system,
it never shows up in
Newton's second law,
so we were never able
to apply the condition
that f static max
was mu static n,
what we call the normal
force between the blocks.
And so we were unable to figure
out what is the maximum force.
All we can say is if I push
f, that's the acceleration.
But I cannot determine what
maximum force will cause block
2 to slip with
respect to block 1.
So when you pick your
system like this,
it's very quick to calculate a.
No problem about that.
But I am not able to
answer any questions that
require some type of information
about the internal forces.
So the art to choosing
systems and free body diagrams
is to think about the types
of questions you're asking.
If you have a question
that involves something
about a maximum condition
on static friction,
then you want to make sure
that static friction is
an external force
to your system.
If it's an internal
force, like in this case,
you will not be able to
apply that condition.